this is what's left of tobruk's house of
representatives building
protesters in the eastern libyan city
stormed it overnight
looting its offices assembly hall and
setting it on fire
this protest came after the political
deadlock and worsening living conditions
in the capital it is clear that the
legislative houses won't come to an
agreement so this protest could pressure
the un mission and the international
community to turn to alternative
solutions
earlier on friday hundreds of young
protesters gathered at this square in
the capital tripoli
living conditions have deteriorated in
recent months after a parallel
government was appointed by the house of
representatives in eastern libya
with power cuts lasting up to 18 hours a
day
there's anger against political leaders
our demands include the removal of
injustice on the citizens
solving the problem of electricity
dissolving and dismantling all
legislative and executive bodies
such as the baba's government
bashaga's government the high state
council parliament aguila salah
2.8 million libyans registered to vote
in elections scheduled for last december
but they were postponed after libya's
two rival parliaments failed to agree on
the rules governing the poll
the disagreement is primarily about who
can run for president the most
controversial candidate is libyan
american warlord khalifa hafter who
controls the oil-rich eastern region
recent u.n mediated talks between the
two sides in cairo and geneva have
failed to achieve consensus
the delegation of the house of
representatives demanded to remove the
condition that presidential candidates
cannot hold any other nationality of
course we categorically rejected this
matter because in this case we are not
putting in general rules but rather it
may be interpreted as tailoring the
rules to allow certain people to run
while the protests got violent in tuberc
and elsewhere they remained largely
peaceful in tripoli the u.n support
mission here in the capital has urged
for calm and restraint what's clear for
now is people are frustrated with those
in power and want elections to be held
if there's no political breakthrough
soon the situation could get worse
malatrina al-jazeera tripoli